(rap music)
("In Your Memory" by FracX)
- [Man] What advice
would you give to someone
who doesn't know what
to do with their life?
- [Gary] To try as
many things as possible
and get into the yes business
instead of the no business.
- [Man] What advice
would you give someone
basically starting
over at 28 years of age.
- [Gary] To realize how lucky
they are that they realize
they should start over.
Or how lucky they are that
they were forced to start over
at an age where
you're still a fucking baby.
- [Man] What is a mantra
or quote you live by?
- [Gary] You're gonna die.
The media
landscape's changing so much.
It's super
interesting because I've been
in this for so long.
- [Interviewer] This
is a big one.
Gary, what's your
ultimate vision for yourself,
your company and the world?
- [Gary] For myself, my
funeral will be attended
by far more people
than anybody realized.
That's for me.
For my company, that
I build one of the great
entrepreneurial media
business empires of all time.
And for the world, that it
continues to do what it's doing
which is at a macro,
it always always always
is better than it
was the day before
even if the headlines trick
you into not believing that.
("What It's Like" by Justin Stone)
- [Gary] This
isn't about social,
this is about the internet.
These are websites
on top of the internet.
That's what those six apps are.
The internet is
what's killing television
or the structure of the
traditional television sense.
You guys know this.
A 14 year old girl,
let her name the five
most famous people to her.
They are not who 38-year-olds
and 54-year-olds think.
- YouTubers and--
- Hundred percent.
Hundred percent.
- I realized I could cultivate
a personal relationship
with millions of people just
by posting one or two things
that speaks directly to them.
- [Gary] Hundred percent.
- And they really lifted me
up when that show came out.
For all intents and purposes,
you would not have known
I was on that show
based on the market.
- [Gary] I get it.
- Then it came out,
and they pushed me.
And so I'm very
grateful to them.
I have a great group
of followers, I guess.
- That's awesome.
- Before the show
started, you had like
35 hundred maybe
followers and now you're like
over 2 million.
- They've been very helpful.
- 'Cause the kids now,
they're reaching for,
they're not
reaching for the weeklys
to see who's doing what,
they're going to social media--
- A hundred thousand percent.
- What you're
doing every single day.
- I feel like they are looking
for personalities, right?
People that they can
connect to and identify with.
And as a young person--
- And always by the way, but
they had no option in the past.
- Thank you man.
- I'll have to get
a copy of your books.
- Oh, let me give you one.
- [Christian] Oh, thank you.
- [Gary] Yeah, yeah.
I want to give you the one
that, if you're gonna read it,
it's gonna
actually bring you value.
Can you get me an #AskGaryVee?
Somebody sent this?
Guys, got it.
Guys, unfortunately
this can never happen.
I was born in the Soviet Union.
Dunk, this can't happen for us.
We weren't born in
this great country.
- I can't become president?
- No. If you're
not born in America,
you can't become president.
- Even if you're
an American citizen?
- Correct.
I'm an American citizen.
- Since birth.
- Oh, you're an
American, right, you can be.
Right, right.
Oh, fuck.
Get outta here.
("Truth" by Shallou)
- [Gary] You
understand psychology.
- Yes.
- [Gary] I understand
what you understand.
- So I, this here I
kind of, it normally
will happen
with fashion couture.
Instagram is a
very democratic platform
and people make a
business by trying to kind of
keep fashion
elusive and exclusive.
So I actually
opened up, like I was
the first Indian designer to
take my shows on Instagram.
So I changed the
format of how I showed
and it's become
super successful for us.
- Makes me happy, man.
It's attention arbitrage, right?
- Right.
- It's wherever the
attention is, is the game.
- Right.
- When there's a coup,
they go after the media.
- Right.
- The media
dictates the mentality.
- Right.
- And that's what
this, I agree man.
You know what the best part is?
If you're an optimist,
which I could tell you are
in four seconds,
if you're an optimist,
this is the greatest
thing that's ever happened
in the world.
- Right. Absolutely.
- I mean the internet is
an incredible thing.
Instagram, for your industry
at this moment at this time,
is disproportionately powerful.
My friend, such a pleasure.
Really nice meeting you.
- Thank you.
("Truth" by Shallou)
- What were the
presentations we've had so far?
- [Group] Strategy.
- [Man 2] I think
culture of the company.
- By the way, for
anybody here who's on,
who plans to build
a very big business,
there will be no
more important meeting
than that one.
The only thing that
allows you to build a business
of any true scale,
scale meaning $50,
$100 million,
like, for real,
it's all people.
DTC,
you know,
container by container,
it's all the stuff you know.
But the right
way is your right way
with knowing that
as much as you can care
about zero
economics,
for as long as possible,
you will win.
The only right way
for a business
to have a heartbeat,
is for it to not be
driven by the wallet.
You know why you're doing it.
I'm a good listener,
for all of my
interrupting in interviews,
you said,
"I have to stay in
it for the legitimacy,"
and you're 100% right.
So, you know
why you're doing it.
So stop complaining
about it to yourself.
You are doing one thing.
- Okay.
- [Gary] It's the engine.
- Got it.
- Got it?
- [Man 3] I'm seeing it
from the wrong angle.
- Yeah, you're looking,
you're doing one thing,
I'm doing one thing,
being GaryVee and
being Gary Vaynerchuk
is one thing.
It seems like it's not.
Got it? You're doing
one thing. Got it?
- [Man 3] Thanks.
- Yeah, that's the game.
You are doing the right thing.
You're gonna go fast now.
You're gonna go faster.
When I tell you
the name has zero,
now, the name may
drive you, you know,
it's fun when you name
something after your child,
there may be that bad
day, two in the morning,
something bad happens, spoiled
shipment, you're fucked,
you look at it and
you're like, "No. Noah."
Right, like
sometimes the name can
do something like that for you,
but it's not the fucking name.
It's not the idea.
It's the execution.
4Ds isn't gonna work
because I randomly
thought of the idea
during a meeting and
then went on Facebook Live,
on Instagram Live,
it's because we're executing.
- Hearing your
culture conversations,
the north star,
what is your north star?
- [Gary] My funeral.
100 fucking thousand percent.
I am so pissed that I don't
get to see my grandchildren
freak the fuck out of how many
people show up to this thing.
I love journeys.
I don't even
want to buy the Jets.
I just want to try to.
I have a video that's super
weird, it's like eight years old
and it's like, it's gonna
be the worst day of my life.
I'm gonna play it.
It's gonna be this crazy day
that all of you are
gonna freak your shit.
America's gonna freak,
I'm gonna make the world care
about me buying the Jets.
And then when it's gonna happen,
everybody's
gonna go fucking crazy.
And whatever TV or Facebook
or video consumption platform
of the time in 20 years is,
I'm gonna play a video.
And it's gonna say, "World.
"This is the
worst day of my life."
That's the most macro.
My love of the chase,
of the climb, of the truth,
the ultimate is
my death.
I'll never be able to get there.
I won't be able to see it.
And that's why it's the
most romantic thing for me.
So, anyway,
that's my north star.
I'm giving you a
really big piece of advice.
I know I'm right,
it's a space I've spent
a lot of time looking at
'cause it's has a lot of
similarities to my tech world,
if you are the person
that can capture the energy
of what I said,
you can't imagine how life
changing that can be for you.
The problem is you
have to have enough talent
to pull it off.
- [Man 4] The AMA's started.
- Let's do it.
- Paul and I are gonna
read you the questions.
- What's up, brother?
It's a pleasure.
- Gary, what are
the three biggest trends
you see in
digital advertising today?
- Audio.
Enormously
passionate about audio.
Believe that podcasting
and Alexa skills
and the Google Home platform,
I believe that audio
is gonna save humans time,
which is why
it's super valuable,
and is not only my number one,
but it's my number two and three
trend that I'm obsessed with.
- What's the best
strategy to gain a following
and to get known
as a hip hop musician
with a poor following?
- You need to
get your music heard.
So, the best way is to actually
make good hip hop music.
'Cause if your
product sucks, you're finished.
But if we assume
that you're good,
I would reach out and DM
on Instagram,
every person
that creates content
and offer your
music for free to them
to be playing in the background
so that you can siphon
their audiences awareness
to hear your music.
And for them,
they're getting the music asset
that might make
their videos better.
You have to bring people value.
What I most want is
the collective home screen
of every 15-year-old in America.
- Why?
- Because I want to
know what one or two things
they're doing that
I don't understand yet,
that then I can
manifest into theses
that will bring me opportunity.
Fuck, we should do this
again, I mean this is--
- [Man 6] This is
Larry King interview style.
- Yeah, this is--
(group talking indistinctly)
- This podcast,
hey podcast peeps,
this is fucking good, right?
Hit me up on Twitter
right now and just say,
"It's good."
How fucking awesome was that?
Let me know,
actually this is a good time,
I'm gonna throw a right hook
because I think I just delivered
fucking the greatest jab
of all time.
If you have not
reviewed my podcast yet,
it would mean the world to me,
and by the way, if you think
my podcast is a piece of shit,
go give me one star,
but if you have
no reviewed it yet,
one way or the other,
this would mean a lot to me
if you would go
and do that right now.
Thanks for listening.
("I Just" by Justin Stone)
Tighten it up.
Yeah.
- [Man 7] Gary
looks like an astronaut.
You look like you're
going to space with that.
- I'm going to space.
Where do you think I'm going?
To the fucking moon, bitch.
("I Just" by Justin Stone)